you know the more dumb things you've
done in your life the more you
experience grace and the longer you live
the more you experience grace and then
the easier it is when someone that you
know or even don't know crashes due to
stupidity the easier it is to extend
grace you know I mean man when I was in
my 20s I was the biggest Pharisee on the
planet can you imagine me as a Pharisee
I mean I cause I'm a real keeper y'all
know I got my rules I tell you what the
rules are you do the rules there's
principles for handling money that work
and when you do them they work and when
you don't do them they don't work and so
don't just don't even ask me about it
just do them right I mean you know how I
am about that but can you imagine in
your personal life Wow have you ever
done something really dumb and you just
wake up feeling like the fool that you
are I guarantee you I of I guarantee I
have I have a PhD in D um B you know I
had a one of my detractors and there are
many of them on the web especially these
days and I think a lot of them used
Twitter is a hobby but I'm saying the
other day that uh you know that was so
Ramsey what are your qualifications for
teaching what you teach you're not
qualified Yeah right let's see all the
scars buddy I got a PhD in D um B men
I've done it all I have made every
stupid mistake that can be made except I
never bought a timeshare that's the one
I haven't done but I think I've done
every one of the other ones that was
dumb I mean I really I mean credit card
man I had them I used to get credit
cards to get credit cards literally I
got credit cards to get credit cards I
would buy subscriptions to financial
magazines because they would sell their
lists to pre-approved credit card
companies and I would get pre-approved
credit cards I was an expert at getting
pre-pre right and a bazillion credit
cards I actually
bought several houses on credit cards I
use credit cards to buy a house one time
I was buying and selling real estate and
this idiot in one of these zero down
financial or zero down real estate
weekend seminars convinced me I and the
rest of the audience or some of the rest
and since you could you know buy a house
on a credit card so I did it I went and
got enough credit cards I bought a house
on a credit card a series of credit
cards just took cash advances on and
closed on the house that's how dumb I am
I better said definitely that's how dumb
I was and you know the idiot teaching
that thing you know the only bigger
idiot was the one in the room me he was
stupid for teaching it but I was the I
was dumber than him I actually went and
did it I tried to lease a car one time
y'all remember those old car I don't
even know if they make them anymore Pujo
a French car I wanted I want I don't
know what was wrong with me I'd lost my
mind I think and I decided I needed a
Pujo so I tried to lease a POJO and they
laughed me out of there because they
pulled up my credit and saw you know
that I had millions of dollars borrowed
all these houses and all these credit
cards to buy houses and all this stuff I
was doing and they're like - the last
thing you need some other payment I went
dude I got payments that's why I got
money I'm I'm rich yeah yeah yeah yeah
they basically ran me off the car lot
and I ended up talking my banker and
loan me money to buy a Jaguar and so
that was the difference that's how
stupid I was
man I've done so many stupid things with
money actually when I got out of school
sharing one of Sharon's old a hole uh
she was a fraternity or what you call a
little sister to a fraternity so this
fraternity guy that she knew came and
called on us and sold us a whole life
life-insurance policy I bought a whole
life policy y'all that's how dumb I am I
had credit cards i car loans I had a
boat loan I borrow on anything man
and then I lost everything because of
that I was foreclosed on I was sued I
was sued so many times the little guy
bringing the lawsuit papers were like on
a first-name basis with the old boy I
mean I was sued and sudents III didn't
just go down I went down in flames I
went down so the fire was so big it made
the newspaper boy wonder child
twenty-something millionaire goes broke
he talked about being shamed and then
ashamed being humiliated and then being
humble there been there may be you
didn't have to go down that big maybe
you weren't as stupid as I was but
you've done some stupid stuff too the
question this show's about is what are
you going to do with the mess you made
what's the next chapter in your book are
you going to keep doing the same thing
over and over again and expect a
different result you're going to keep
eating like you're eating and expecting
your waistline to change you can keep
spending like you're spending not
communicating with your spouse leasing
cars using a stupid credit card buying
whole life policies and time shares and
then scratching your head and wondering
why in the richest country in the world
you're still freaking broke are you
going to keep doing the same thing over
and over again and expect a different
result
the 12-steppers say that's the
definition of insanity you keep doing
what you've been doing you're going to
keep getting what you've been getting
you plant corn don't be shocked corn
grows look at that where that corn come
from you dummy you put it in the ground
you plant poison you know it grows
poison don't be shocked where'd that
come from you planted it the Bible says
we reap what we sow
that's all that means we live in a
cause-and-effect world when you go
around doing stupid your life is going
to look desperate and broke all the time
your life's going to look like a bad
blame country song I know I've been that
country song I know exactly what it
looks like keep the dog on the street
he's gonna get hit next I mean there's
something going on I hear a three-legged
dog named lucky I mean what's you know
really seriously but we live our lives
this way and you walk around acting like
everything's okay
carrying that purse wearing those shoes
driving that car going on that vacation
and you're just plain stupid and inside
you know it
the thing is I'm trying to tell you
you're not different than anybody else
most people are stupid when it comes to
money that's why most people are broke
they look good they're driving nice
stuff that they can't afford they're
going on vacations they can't afford
living in a place that can't afford they
eat out every freaking night like they
don't have a stove least learn to use a
dad-blame microwave
I mean seriously when are you gonna
change you work your whole life for what
an illusion a facade why don't you work
your life right become wealthy you make
enough money to become wealthy but you
got to take stupid out of the equation
and you got us take faking it out of the
equation one of the biggest benefits of
me going broke was I no longer care what
you think
it's really freeing I Drive a really
nice car now some people don't like that
I don't care when I was driving a junk
car people made fun of that I don't care
I'll Drive a car for you I Drive a car
for me you ain't riding in my car so
shut up
when you don't care what people think it
changes everything you guys so what are
you going to do about you so you can win
you got this you got to stop the stupid
time to unplug it hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income